as promised Bernie Sanders has released
10 years of tax returns and as predicted
not shockingly not surprisingly Bernie's
net worth at nearly 80 years of age is a
little over a million dollars in 2018 he
and his wife made a combined five
hundred sixty six thousand dollars most
of it was from Bernie's book the rest
was his Senate salary of about a hundred
and seventy five thousand dollars and
immediately people on the right and some
anti Bernie components of the left
started smearing Bernie as a millionaire
which is pathetic it's a ridiculous
attack as I told you last week it's not
remarkable I don't want to redo all of
last week's story but at nearly 80 years
of age having a million dollars is not
that remarkable five hundred and
sixty-six thousand in income puts Bernie
in the 1% income wise he achieved that
status once he was 75 years old and as I
told you last week back in 2016 a
million dollars was about the average
net worth for people Bernie's age about
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
was the median net worth and Bernie as a
US senator has more wealth than the
median for people his age and has right
about the average so I don't want to
pretend that Bernie having a million
bucks isn't a lot of money he's very
fortunate to have it but I hate to break
it to you that having a million dollars
including real estate at 77 years of age
doesn't make Bernie the fat cat rich
dude that is the problem with society
and often times you know people aren't
supposed to talk about this in big
cities Boston New York lots of people
even people who just went right into
finance when they got out of school they
have a million dollar net worth in their
early 30s and they actually are in the
top 1% of net worth for their age Bernie
achieved it in his mid-70s and I'm not
pretending once again Pat that it's not
a lot of money I'm not pretending that
40% of the country can't meet a small
unexpected financial expense we've
talked about that and it's all true but
Bernie's wealth isn't the problem and
more importantly Bernie has the right
policies for the poor and middle class
and that's really what matters here yeah
I don't see any hypocrisy when he talks
about income inequality in the top
% having so much wealth he's really
talking about a fraction of the top 1%
it's the people who have hundreds of
millions of dollars or even billions of
dollars that just kind of hoard that
money and don't reinvest it back into
the economy if you have a net worth of a
million or a few million at the age of
77 as he is it's really not that
significant and it also depends on how
you made that money like if you wrote a
book or if you were a doctor or a lawyer
he has no gripe against that and this
has all happened in the last three years
because Bernie's policies have resonated
with people and people wanted to read
the guy's book Trump is really rich he's
a billionaire but his policies are
terrible for the poor and middle class
that's what I care about Mitt Romney who
ran in 2012 he's really rich about two
hundred and fifty million dollar net
worth if I recall correctly his policies
would have been good mostly for the rich
Bernie Sanders as a million bucks for
decades his policies have been those
that consistently would work to elevate
the poor and the middle class period and
to understand the hypocrisy the right
loves to say that when people on the
Left don't have money and they want to
pass laws to help the poor in the middle
class the right says oh they're bitter
because they don't have money now Bernie
has a million bucks at age 77 and all of
a sudden he's either a hypocrite or not
really the guy that's going to help the
poor in middle class
give me a break okay the policies have
been the same for decades and meanwhile
the first question last night at
Bernie's town hall was from a student
who is also a campus coordinator for the
right-wing group Turning Point USA who
said to Bernie now that you're in the 1%
are you going to pay your fair share
these are just stupid smears and whether
you're for Bernie or for someone else
don't fall for them don't foment them
don't buy into them today's program was
made possible in part by a simple habit
an app for iOS Android and web browser
that gives you access to more than 2,000
guided meditations you can try it free
for one week by going to simple habit
comm slash Pakman simple habit has
meditations made specifically for
anxiety falling asleep overcoming
procrastination getting focused there's
a meditation for almost anything you are
dealing with in life and there is
constantly
new scientific research emerging about
the benefits of meditating regarding
your physical health your mental
well-being your social life your
cognitive performance it's a long list
I personally make meditation part of my
day I've been doing it for a while and
simple habit makes it incredibly easy to
stick to a meditation routine each
guided meditation is just five minutes
long they have meditations specifically
designed for waking up for your daily
commute when you get home from work
every part of your day
the massive variety of different kinds
of meditations that simple habit offers
is what really sets the app apart and
they just won the 2018 Google Play award
for best well-being app you can try it
completely free for a week by going to
simple habit calm slash Pakman I think
you'll love it I've put a link right
underneath this video